there's a letter
from the vice president of the United
States to Dylan Mulvaney
Dylan Mulvaney the most famous woman in
America
she writes with the the letterhead of
the vice president
dear Dylan I send you my warmest
readings as you celebrate your 365th day
of living authentically
thank you for courageously sharing your
story and your journey I appreciate your
continued advocacy for transgender
equality including during your visit to
the White House last year blah blah blah
blah blah sincerely Kamala Harris
authentically
yes yes
if there is one word that comes to mind
when I think of Dylan Mulvaney it is
authentic
of course he's not living authentically
he's living the opposite of
authentically
he is a man and he's pretending to be a
woman but furthermore there was a clip
that just came out of Dylan Mulvaney
before he dressed up like a woman on The
Price is Right and he was behaving in
exactly the same way he behaves in now
in a way that he says is how a woman
behaves very over the top very Fabish
and attention seeking
now is that authentic I don't know I
mean it's clearly performed it's
obviously very very conscious
but maybe he just is authentically an
attention seeker he's certainly very
theatrical he is he was a Broadway actor
the emphasis on authenticity
is a big
problem in our culture because the focus
on authenticity turns all of our
attention on ourselves say am I the
thing that I just did is that really me
is that really me or is was I doing
someone else I don't I don't know what
do I real what's my real desire am I
what's my true uh
sexual inclination what's my true
fashion style what's my true uh
professional calling what's my true
what's my authentic what's my this
what's my that
and it's it it's a Fool's errand to
think in that way because a man wrapped
up in himself makes a small package
indeed
especially because man is mimetic we we
grow we learn we are educated by
imitating others that's true of little
babies that's true of adults we imitate
the way that someone we admire speaks we
imitate the way that they think we
imitate the things that they read we
imitate the way that they dress we we
imitate
everything we imitate their desires we
desire certain things because they
desire those things
so
the the
way to live in a flourishing way is not
to just look at yourself and then
imitate yourself in this infinitely
regressive way and recursive way until
you're talking about nothing at all it's
to look elsewhere say how did how do
they live that hey that that good person
over there I'm going to imitate that
person I'm going to live authentically
as that person or that even better
person or ultimately what you're trying
to do is imitate God it's this is the
idea of the imitation of Christ and this
is the idea of putting your focus all on
God and then
trying to behave that way what would
Jesus do if you do that you're going
you're not going to be living
authentically as yourself but
paradoxically you will be living most
authentically as yourself because you
were made in the image and likeness of
God and you were made to do good so do
it the current administration's New
Year's goals are to tax spend and turn a
blind eye to inflation if this is at
odds with your goals you're tired of the
government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over 5
000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil stock market
crashes now you can own gold and attack
sheltered retirement account Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA in Precious Metals text
nulls Canon wlas 298 9898 to claim your
free info kit on gold and then talk to
one of their precious metals Specialists
with an A plus rating With Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings text Knowles can it
be Les to 99 98.98 and protect yourself
with gold today that is Knowles Canada
w-les to 98 98 98
today
there is some good news out of higher
education you remember a week or two ago
Stanford law had that horrific display
where a judge the fifth Circuit Judge
Kyle Duncan came to town and was giving
a lecture in these lunatic students
these students who obviously should
never been admitted certainly should be
expelled certainly should never become
lawyers they come out they start
screaming obscenities weird sexual
obscenities uh all sorts of four-letter
words that this guy to shut him up from
speaking at a federalist Society event
so at that point a dean of diversity and
inclusion walks in takes the side of the
screaming banshee students
starts yelling at the judge and I said
at the time if the students aren't
expelled and the dean isn't fired then
were
we're just seeing empty talk
okay yes Stanford apologizes but talk is
cheap okay show me some action well
we're starting to see some action the
the dean of Stanford law school Jenny
Martinez doubled down on her support of
free speech in a memo on Wednesday
and then the diversity Dean Tyrion
Steinbach
joined the uh disruptors and she has
been placed on leave
she's been placed on leave she now just
just moments ago published an op-ed in
which she came out against Free Speech
she said that her job was to de-escalate
the situation not to defend Stanford's
Free Speech policy first of all your job
is to enforce the rules and standards of
the University broadly you're an
administrator at the at the University
that is that should be one of your jobs
now she's right in as much as her role
as dean of diversity is to undermine
everything the university stands for
that's what these administrators do
their job is to stir the pot they are
not doing their job if they're not
constantly stirring the pot undermining
the rules of the University undermining
The Pursuit Of Truth undermining
academic standards and and ginning up
racial grievance about nonsense and
imaginary problems so that is her job
she's been placed on leave now
being placed on leave is usually what
happens when your employers are hoping
that something will blow over
so we got to go further
and I think she may have helped us go
further here because by publishing this
op-ed she's basically daring Stanford to
fire her
and Stanford should fire if Stanford
doesn't fire her now
it's going to look so so weak it's true
that firing her is going to lead to all
sorts of lawsuits it's okay there are
plenty of good lawyers at Stanford law
I've been told go for it we've also got
some great news speaking of schools
on
on the education front we so rarely have
good news on the education front but
Florida has become the sixth state to
enact school choice into law that's
after West Virginia Arizona Iowa Utah
Arkansas now we've got Florida why is
Florida doing this well one because
Rhonda Santos is a very good governor
and he's obviously running for president
so he's gonna score as many wins on that
board as he can before he formally
announces but
what explains the push in all of these
other states why School choices become
more popular because Republicans have
been talking about school choice for
ever why is it now the the consensus
wisdom
is that the reason that school choice is
winning now is because during lockdown
the kids came home and the parents were
able to see what they were being taught
in schools because the the learning
started to take place on laptops and the
parents could be in the back of the room
and the parents were so shocked at what
the kids were being taught in schools
that this renewed and a push for school
choice maybe that plays a role into it I
have a little bit of a different take
though
I think that that one of the big reasons
that school choice is winning now is
because
parents recognized
the possibility of Alternatives in
education
I think humans are creatures of habit
and we can get stuck in a rut and we can
lose our imagination and think that if
something is a certain way right now it
always has to be that way
and so yes parents saw that their kids
education was
even crazier than they previously
thought but they knew it was a little
bit crazy
the kids are coming home and talking
about all this weird stuff that
transgender and the Pan's gender and the
thank you ma'am gender and all the rest
of it so they know that it's like that
scene in in The Sopranos when AJ comes
home and he's talking to Anthony and
Carmella and he says America is a
terrible place and Columbus was a
genocidal maniac and then Tony starts
screaming at him
parents know that their kids are being
taught nonsense in schools
they didn't know there was an
alternative and then for two years the
kids were sitting at home
on their computers
parents were exploring homeschool pods
they were exploring certain private
education methods and they were they
were recognizing that the education was
not particularly high quality and they
said wow another option is available I
think if people just see that there are
choices if people just see that they're
not stuck in with whatever the libs hand
them
that that gives people a lot of
encouragement and courage is not only a
virtue but the prerequisite for all of
the other virtues push ahead we've got
six states here that means that we've
got
44 to go today's fake headline Friday
I've got more mailbag questions to get
to we will get to that you will help me
to pick the correct
or the fake headline rather out of the
five that Mr Davies is trying to stump
me on the only way to do it is to become
a member of the creme de La Creme
out here on YouTube Just
like a leech sucking up all this free
content without parting with your
hard-earned money so that you can help
me figure out which headline is fake on
Fridays no no
you've got to join that inner circle
La Crema
over at dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
all right